every camp every clinic around america i
go and talk to kids
they don't ask me how did it feel to
play 19 years how did it feel to play
with dirk or win it win a championship
yeah what question is how did it feel
for lebron to dunk on you like that
all right come on man get out of here
[Music]
new year new season of untold stories
we're listening what the fans want
we started off from football now we're
branching off across different sports
so who we got in the pool hall today hey
oh we got the jet on the runway yes sir
thanks for terry what's good with you
baby
this is one of my favorite episodes we
bout to do because this is talking about
my favorite team in the world
dallas mavericks man and you've had some
great memories on that team man we going
to get into that but i got to see how
nice you on this table man
oh yeah oh yeah go ahead and break man
come on man i got a little bit of
some drop ball
going into 2011 what was the confidence
level
that you had and what was the confidence
level the team had well you already know
the ultimate ultimate ultimate
prediction right
not the week before the game or the day
of the game
like this is in pre-season in training
camp we're at deshawn stevenson's house
we're having some team bonding and we
walk in man
and he's like man i got a tattoo on this
man gonna come through
you know y'all get whatever you want
it's on me like oh okay cool
me i'm a man of many tattoos all of them
have meaning
but this time i was like man i'm about
to do something and so i get the larry
o'brien trophy
tatted on my bicep but i didn't reveal
it that night
wrapped it up well then i shoot around
the next day we're in orlando coach carl
bring it in everybody okay let's get
ready to roll tonight
i'm like hold up fellas i got something
for you and i unwrapped it
boom and then i flexed but it was like
crickets like everyone was looking
around
and dirk just bust out this guy is crazy
he's a circus look at this guy i'm like
nah man i'm serious i think we got the
team that's gonna do it
and then we went on our journey
oh got a pool shark in the building
i know i know what time it is now game
six i was espn dallas intern
watching the fan watch that was going on
american airlines center while y'all was
in miami
seconds countdown you see dirk hopping
off the floor
every team is doing this now where you
see them going to vegas going to a big
club
after they win a championship and
celebrating y'all was the first ones
really keeping this thing lit on social
media i was geeked i didn't know what to
do i couldn't go to sleep and i was 20.
so i can go out of bars you know i
didn't have a fake id
that was the biggest celebration ever in
their history because
you did it in their city the owner is
with you he's striking up the van like
you don't see that you don't see owners
like really just
out there but to walk through their
prestigious club live
with the trophy one and then this big
ass
wheelbarrow of ice to this day i haven't
seen a bottle of champagne that bit and
it was probably
at least three quarters of this pool
table reportedly that tab was 110 000
wow what do you remember from that night
man cause i'm mad i wasn't there
man i remember lil wayne definitely gave
us a shout out on the mic
i remember cuban get on the stage with
the mic dirk was on stage with the mic
after that it's a blur let's get a shot
at real quick yep
you're there for another year at the
mavs try to do this repeat
doesn't work out from there you go to
boston same level confidence
oh man now i'm an nba champion
i'm about to go join some other
champions growing up it was celtics
lakers that was the rival you watched it
like that was our social media
uh you wanted to see what those two are
gonna do now i get to join that
franchise
and for me it's like man we got a real
shot miami was still running things in
the east 100
i was there one year but i will tell you
this boston got some of the greatest
sports fans ever
and every time i go back it's all love
like
you would think i won a championship and
played there like my whole career you
think i was just trying that tattoo what
do you think it's from
it couldn't have been how awful how
lebron did me right yeah
how he mimified me talk to me what what
do you remember about that play what do
you remember about that moment
i want to say it's one of the lowest
moments in my career but at the same
time
i mean i'll forever go down in history
like you got dunked on
every camp every clinic around america i
go and talk to kids
they don't act like man how did it feel
to play 19 years how did it feel to play
with dirk or win it
win a championship yeah what question is
how did it feel for lebron to dunk on
you like that
all right come on man get out of here
was it a fast break
it was a fast break but what happened
was i was coming down i
turned the ball off okay so it's just
instinct for me when you turn it over i
got to get it back so i'm chasing it i
might have chased the whole team in the
coach
trying to get the ball back i got
chalmers coming at me and then lebron's
coming down the middle took my off
lebron for one second
chase chalmers turned back around and
he was already in the air right in slow
motion
if what made me jump is what i'm trying
to figure out
like even if you did jump you're not
going to touch
me touching that oh and i jumped man and
he lifted me on his knee
and i was still going up with him like
lebron just bang bang it was over like
i elevated i was in the rim hit the
ground man
i didn't hop up quick i laid there for a
minute and i think that's the picture of
the meme that's out
like i'm laying there with my arms like
being a funeral man
i get in front bro i was one of those
people on social media that was not
laughing at this moment for three weeks
i was checking my phone
and people were sending me you okay like
numbers i haven't heard in eight
years i'm seeing numbers pop up jet you
are you good
damn big homie you're good i don't know
what these people talking about
david said in wikipedia they said that
was my death date and they had to date
and everything on there that's crazy man
the internet don't give a damn about
nobody bro
what was the response from your
teammates like who's killing me in the
locker room destroying
jokes and jokes and jokes i'm telling
you it kept up for a while
all right
jason terry you got 60 seconds see how
many shots you can get in but also let's
see any questions you can answer you
ready
man this is what i do all right let's
get it man let's start this thing off
right
in three two one let's get it
more fun playing with dirk or kg kg
jet do you prefer private jets a
commercial man private
celtics and mavs don't let me down come
on man let's go baby
uh luca yanus like drake said both
vivid memory of the warriors mad series
man when dirk threw the chair
and put a hole in the stadium best
three-point shoot in nba history
steph curry best trash talk you've ever
played with
kevin garnett who did more for the
headband you were lebron
oh yours truly who's the real jet you
are kenny smith the jet by name and not
by game
i'm sorry kenny smith best city you've
ever visited on the road
seattle seattle all-star weekend of
super bowl week all-star
mj lebron mj funniest teammate you've
ever had
greg buckner loudest locker room guy you
ever played
corey brewer eight seconds free game
snack routine that you've ever had
chicken fingers
who are you listening to before a game
man man nipsey hustlers are great
and that's tom right there 28 scores
we're gonna end this on the marathon
continues
man appreciate you pulling up on the
pool hall with us man
subscribe to bleacher report for more
untold stories